pékin et new delhi sont tombés d'accord
pour apaiser la situation entre leurs
armées
un appel téléphonique entre les chefs de
la diplomatie indienne et chinoise a
permis de diminuer la tension entre les
deux géants asiatiques dans la nuit de
lundi à mardi un accrochage a lieu dans
la vallée de galles one situé dans le
nord de l'inde
les soldats des deux côtés se sont
affrontés dans un corps à corps à coups
de poing de pierres et de barres de fer
la confrontation a fait 20 victimes du
côté de l'inde la chine a elle refusé de
confirmer des pertes selon des médias
indiens au moins 40 soldats chinois
auraient été tuées ou grièvement
blessées
le premier ministre n'a rennes drame
audi assure que son pays ne désire pas
d'affrontement mais qu'il se tient prêt
à se défendre
les guînes l'inde veut la paix mais mais
est toujours capable de donner une
réponse appropriée si elle est provoquée
je veux assurer le pays que le sacrifice
de nos soldats n'aura pas été en vain
pékin assure aussi vouloir mettre un
terme à la confrontation
du côté chinois
nous ne voulons assurément plus voire
deux heures qu'on doit d'à propos
la russie a elle salué cette désescalade
entre les deux voisins aux gens beaux
habits blancs mostow il a déjà été
annoncé que les représentants militaires
d'inde et de chine sont entrés en
contact
il évoque la situation les mesures en
vue d'une désescalade
nous saluons cela on peut y voir l'inde
et la chine ont plusieurs litiges
territoriaux depuis le dernier conflit
ouvert entre les deux nations en 1962
après un incident au début du mois de
mai les deux armées sont engagés dans
plusieurs face à face tendu le long de
la frontière contestée